[Musique]
personne avant lui n'y avait pensé ce
devait être une première mondiale
celui qui depuis quatre jours tenter de
battre les limites qu'il s'était fixé
dans sa discipline le vélo d'appartement
s'est arrêté en route
il nous laisse vous le rappelle faire du
surplace sur une distance équivalente au
paris-dakar l'histoire d'un record
impossible michel rivière un regard
comme une idée fixe une respiration
ponctuée par un compte-tours et derrière
la tête un fantasme lancinant depuis
cinq mois
parcourir 2500 km sur un vélo
d'appartement ou comment pédaler
longtemps mais pas n'importe comment
un challenge alain gérard 35 ans prof de
gym de son état avait lui même fixé les
données quelle vitesse allez-vous
pédaler pendant ces cinq jours
alors pendant ces cinq jours j'ai pédalé
à 32 moyenne de vitesse constante une
vitesse constante
à force aujourd'hui
l'envers du décor 1347 kilomètres
parcourus au lieu de 2500 un plouf
symbolique dans la méditerranée au lieu
de l'afrique rêvée la femme quoi j'ai eu
un problème
4e
d'entrée jouer le jeu c'est à dire de
pédaler sur un vélo d'appartement nous
n'a pas tout en suivant tout à fait
régulière bon j'aurai une mine nous
sommes aperçus que petit à petit secret
un problème de tendinite n'est pas un
échec je regrette c'est pas un échec il
ya eu dans ma mère fort et la
transpiration
non je mange mon physiquement bon je lui
dirai qu'on compte que sportif il n'aime
pas perdre
et moi je suis un gagnant n'est pas
arriver en disant qu'elle était à 2500
km c'était faisable si je pouvais y
arriver
une consolation néanmoins pour un
algérien ces six cent mille tours de
pédalier en quatre jours sont
aujourd'hui consignées dans le livre des
records
un record qu'il envisage d'ailleurs de
battre et avec le sourire cette fois ci
dès la saison prochaine
[Musique]